bonsoir à tous j'aime bien invité de
temps en temps des auteurs débutants
donc de vous et de moi inconnue et les
invités avec un auteur célèbre
chevronnés dont chaque livre est un
événement en librairie ce soir cet
auteur célèbre ce sera régine deforges
la star et les débutants ils seront six
ces débutants
là
à
tous les écrivains que vous venez de
voir générique ce sont des auteurs
célèbres des stars et leurs portraits en
noir et blanc sont extraits de ce album
qui est très talentueux photographe en
quête d'auteur ce sont soixante
photographies d'écrivains réalisée par
les photographes de l'agencé vu je veux
commencer par présenter les débutants j
ai envie d été ils étaient six andré le
gall vous êtes journaliste enfin vous
avez été journaliste actuellement
producteur d'émissions sur france
culture
votre premier roman est un roman
d'aventurés intitulé le shanghai et aux
éditions jean claude lattès à côté de
vous clos de tarder à vous êtes
professeur de lettres dans un lycée de
l'île et vous publie aux éditions
mazarine premier roman aussi une mort
sucre et bernard lortholary venait de
maître de conférences d'allemand à la
sorbonne des traducteurs entre autres de
kafka de max frisch de quand d'autres et
vous allez aussi le traducteur d'un
auteur évidemment tout à fait inconnu
allemand patrick süskind dont le premier
roman le parfum histoire d'un meurtrier
viennent pas aux éditions fayard
donc vous l'avez traduit également et
c'est vous qui nous en parlerait ohana
au relais à vous êtes roumaine vous avez
traduit vous avez cette région réfugié
politique en france va publier sept roms
en roumanie alors des médias qu'est ce
que vous faites là oublié des des
débutants mais vous êtes une certaine
manière une débutants puisque vous venez
de faire paraître en france votre
premier roman écrit en français
directement ce qui n'est pas rien quand
on a écrit et sept romans dans une autre
langue
alors ce roman c'est utile un sosie en
cabale est paru aux éditions du seuil
marie-claude beineix vous êtes passés de
la peinture à l'écriture avec ce premier
roman intitulé pire aux femelles aux
éditions stock
pierre veilletet vous êtes journaliste
prix albert londres vous êtes rédacteur
en chef de sud ouest dimanche est votre
premier roman paru chez un nouvel
éditeur les éditions arléa à rl aux
accents aigus à votre premier roman la
pension des nonnes et puis alors donc la
star régine deforges gvoice à vous ça
vous chagrine ou ça vous fait plaisir je
vous appelle star ça ne me gêne pas mais
ça me surprend toujours j'ai presque
envie de me retourner en demandant dès
qu'il s'agit mais j'ai toujours voulu
être célèbre commandé alors je vais pas
m'en plaindre maintenant
non parce que je trouve vous êtes
vraiment une star aujourd'hui parce que
la star c'est quelqu'un qui a une grande
notoriété une grande popularité vous
l'avez depuis la bicyclette bleue qui a
été un succès phénoménal
vous êtes belle il faudrait qu'à la
physique et vous êtes riche maintenant
et en plus de ça il y a quand même et
les plus grandes stars ont toujours
quand même une sorte un peu d'ombré
quand même autour d'elle il ya une
auréole un peu de soufre quand même qui
vous qui vous suit et on va le voir
d'ailleurs avec avec ce roman le il ya
une et karen cheryl la chanteuse a dit
de vous dans le france soir de lundi
elle dit vous étiez la marquise de sade
reconverti en comtesse de ségur
je trouvais ça assez joli oui parce que
rien ne peut me faire plus de plaisir
que d'être comparée à la comtesse de
ségur que je considère comme un grand
écrivain du 19ème et qui a été c'était
même même les premières lectures et je
faisais j'adapte et même certains
moments de la campagne où je faisais
lesquels de théâtre avec et le marquis
de sade ne vous déplaît pas non plus a
pas du tout mais c'est d'autant moins
que c est un auteur qui va se retrouver
rééditer ces derniers temps et puis vous
êtes une star parce que tous les médias
s'arrachent régine deforges régine
par-ci régine par là aujourd'hui je sois
l'a25 demain vous serez sur l'a8
vraiment vous êtes vraiment très
demandée c'est bien ça me fait plaisir
ça me fait plaisir mais encore une fois
je trouve ça un petit peu étonnant et je
me dis quelquefois mais il ya donc pas
d'autres personnes pourquoi est ce qu'on
me demande tellement à moi en ce moment
ah ben oui non mais je sais aussi que
les choses sont d'une certaine façon
pendant un temps et que demain après
demain elles peuvent être autrement
donc si vous voulez je prends plaisir à
ce qui se passe maintenant en dix ans
demain est un autre jour
alors vous allez de faire pareil vous y
sur le b michel un court roman par
lettres intitulé pour l'amour de marie
sala et qui est née de la lecture de
carte postale tout à fait de découvertes
de cartes postales chez un brocanteur de
giroud et sur la cinquantaine de cartes
postales à l'acheter y en avait 3 dont
la lecture nous avait vraiment beaucoup
troublé via et moi et ce car ces quatre
c'était les lettres d'amour d'une femme
à une autre femme
alors le lendemain sert précipiter chez
le brocanteur refouiller dans les bois
et j'ai retrouvé quatre autres cartes
postales et je me suis dit ça ferait une
belle histoire
puis voilà et puis on dans trois ans
j'ai pensé tout en écrivant autre chose
je pensais à ce livre que j'écrirais un
jour et puis là n'ayant pas tellement le
temps de me lancer dans un dans un grand
roman qui demanderait un angle de
travail j'avais envie d'écrire
j'écris donc ça a été avant une autre
trilogie peut-être cette sorte de
récréation mais j'étais tombé moi aussi
amoureuse c'est ça oui un tel que je les
y
les deux femmes l'une s'appelle
marguerite margot tr min ce qu'elle va
rentrer dans l'intimité de l'autre
alors elle c'est la conquérante celle
amoureuse c'est celle qui ne craque pas
le qu'en-dira-t-on qui est vraiment très
amoureuse de mari oui c'est elle qui va
en fait conquérir lowe's qui va faire
que cette jeune femme puisqu'elle sont
marié marié toutes les deux va oser
déclarer son amour à marie qui va pas y
être insensible les ça va être une
véritable histoire et marie alors au
contraire elle est plus timide elle
craint ce qu'on pourrait dire dans le
village de leur amour vous savez des
village de 300 habitants c'est toujours
un petit peu effrayant que ce soit en
1904 au maintenant donc elle a peur et l
on est là une impression aussi que ce
n'est pas bien
éducation
chrétienne est encore très fortes elles
vont à la messe au début du siècle
c'est au début du siècle donc qu'est-ce
qui fait des créations marier toutes les
deux toutes les deux sont arrivés et
qu'elles ont même des enfants
oui c'est pas un compte at il oui non
mais je verse ajoute quand même oui ça
ajoute mais ça n'ajoute pas si vous
voulez ça n'entre pas dans dans leurs
amours le fait qu'elle soit mariée
toutes les deux ça les embête mais ça
n'est pas un élément de plus oui pas
facile parce que comme lui ne va être
enceinte
c'est une sorte de trahison de l'amour
c'est une sorte de trahison d'ailleurs
leur amour s'arrêtera là les est ce
qu'il n'ya pas là dans ce dans ce livre
je dirais presque une réminiscence
nostalgiques de de vos amours de jeunes
filles pour des personnes de votre sexe
pour son accueil et volets et bien sûr
écouter vraiment non on peut
effectivement on peut y penser je pense
que des lecteurs et penseront n'est pas
du tout je me suis senti aussi à l'aise
on imagine en cet amour là qu'en
imaginant l'amour d'un homme et d'une
femme
tout d'un coup j'étais l'une ou l'autre
oui sauf que c'est un mot qui est très
contrarié parce qu'il doit se cacher
sans arrêt sont des lettres
la preuve c'est que se disent
l'essentiel par lettre elles se disent
l'essentiel par let et puis j'ai essayé
de ne pas tous trop dire parce que je
crois beaucoup aux non dits dans l'est
dans les romans je crois beaucoup que le
lecteur doit avoir sa part de travail
dans la lecture ou dans dans pour le
développement de l'histoire
ce qui m'intéressait de se décider de ne
pas trop dire ce qui se passait autour
d'un oui d'ailleurs le l'endroit où se
passent leur amour finalement et eu
enfin bon c'est une grange mais c'est
tout mayouf qu'une des deux va faire la
description à l'autre de la grange
bien sûr que non plus qu'elle la voit
tous les jours puisqu'elle se voit tous
les jours mais vous en revanche vous
voyez très bien la grange j'allais dire
comme s'il y était comme si vous y étiez
mais vous
évidemment vous l'avez cette description
vous la gardez pour vous je la garde
pour moi parce que je pense que le
lecteur il peut aussi bien voir cette
branche que moi et